oui !
Oui ! *très heureux*
On est en Live !
Il faut deviner le poids, de John Rachid.
Mais naaan ?
*rire*
Attends e elle deconne la balance frère !
Ah 50 kilos ?
Ah ?
95 ?
JR: C'est un poids avec plein d'micros et tout. Je suis pas gros hein
NT: C'est une balance qui déconne
NT: Il y a une bonne réponse sur twitter mais peut être que Drazozo a la bonne réponse.
Voix au téléphone : 90
NT: Attention, je suis pas aussi gros que ça, calme toi., qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
Voix au téléphone : 76
NT : Re-perdu
JR: C'est mon année de naissance
Voice on the phone : 84 ?
*musique we are the champion de Queen*
NT: merci ! merci beaucoup
JR: tu choisis
Voix : je sais pas vous avez des téléphones
JR: Non non mais arrête de croire
NT: le mec, il a cru que c'était une boutique
NT: Oh my god ! That's real ! Tu as gagné une sorte de tablette de gaming !
Allez hop là !
Ha il est content il est content !
J'ai l'impression d’être animateur sur skyrock quand on vois le cadeau tout de suite
et qu'on est a la Skyroulette, c'est génial !
je vais te faire le quizz vrai & faux
Norman a arrêté les cours en 4ème
VRAI ou faux
FAUX
c'est faux
Par contre moi oui
Norman est ambidextre
ça veut dire qu'il peut écrire de la main droite et de la
gauche. Vrai ou Faux?
C'est vrai ?
##Ahah ### Abonne toi à Drazozo
voila
Alors, c'est complêtement FAUX
Tu as perdu
Hachid à son passeport francais, vrai ou faux ?
Bah vrai
C'est FAUX !  NT : Il ne l'a pas du tout JR: Tu n'as pas vu ma vidéo
Va voir ma dernière vidéo sur Cuba
Je le dit que je ne l'ai pas mon passeport français
Vrai ou faux, Mister V a grandis dans les quartiers chaud de Grenoble ?
Euh, ça c'est FAUX
C'est faux *BRAVO * APPLAUDISSEMENT
C'est complétement faux, tu gagnes un point
Il a totalement grandi dans une résidence
Hugo Tout Seul est noir
Vrai ou faux? *voix* Faux JR: On dirait qu'il y croit un peu NT: Ah oui
Il pourrait porter un boubou sans problème *rires*
JR: Est-ce que Norman est aussi un nom de sapin?
Oui. JR: OUI, VRAI, BRAVO
NT: Dans Jhon Rachid
NT: Il y a une faute d'orthographe pas faite exprès lors de sa création
*voix* VRAI. NT et JR : Il a gagné *Enthousiasme*
*musique We are champions par QUEEN*
NT: Respire bien fort JR: C'est ouf. NT: Tu vas gagner
Mon gars JR: UNE PS4 NT: UNEPS4
on  a un cadeau a t'offrir c'est celui la
si c'est un livre c'est cool j'aime bien les livre
c'est un livre *rire*
j'adore les livre moi aussi j'adore les livre il a vue une ps4 il est dégouter
il faut donner des indice
elle est écrie par qu'elle qu'un de connue
elle est sortie il y a très peut de temps tu peut taper livre sur Google
c'est Roger et c'est humain